hi i'm christine goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown the supreme
court reviews challenges to the biden
administration's emergency covit 19
vaccine regulations for private
employers and health care centers fox
news at night anchor and chief legal
correspondent shannon breme breaks down
the legal arguments for both sides of
the issue
and while covet 19 cases continue to
rise across the nation johns hopkins
senior scholar dr amesha dalja joins the
rundown to explain how the rapid spread
of the omicron variant and vaccines
preventing serious illness is good news
in america's ongoing fight against the
virus plus commentary by fox news senior
meteorologist janis dean the fox news
rundown is a daily news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player by going to
foxnewspodcast.com
i'm shannon breme i'm bill hemmer i'm
kennedy and this is the fox news rundown
friday january 7th 2022 i'm chris foster
the supreme court takes up president
biden's coronavirus vaccine mandates
today you could definitely put together
five justices who would say listen we're
in a unique time in history the federal
government is doing everything that it
can
and in their assessment their judgment
they think this will lessen cases and
severity of illness and death and you
know they've got a right to do it we
speak with fox news host and chief legal
correspondent shannon breem
i'm alex hogan kids ages 12 to 15 join
those eligible for the booster but as
new variants emerge in the future how
often will we need these extra jabs it
comes back to what the goals may be with
covet 19 control are we trying to
prevent serious illness hospitalization
and death or are we trying to block all
infections
and i'm janis dean i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
the supreme court's hearing challenges
to biden administration coronavirus
vaccine mandates that would cover about
100 million americans one mandate covers
employees of large businesses that comes
from the occupational safety and health
administration osha that was supposed to
go into effect this week but it's been
pushed back because of the lawsuits
white house spokeswoman jen saki says a
lot of companies are just doing it on
their own almost two-thirds of companies
have taken steps to put in place
either either vaccination requirements
or testing requirements they're all
implementing it in a different way and
the leadership of these companies is
making a decision about what works best
for their workforce giving that option
is something certainly we support
another mandate covering health care
workers comes from the centers for
medicare and medicaid services louisiana
attorney general jeff landry led a
lawsuit joined by 13 other states asking
the courts to block that he tells fox
states and individuals are sovereign we
should not be able we should not have
the government forcing us to do anything
both mandates were announced in november
the first one deals with companies that
have more than 100 employees so what
happens here is osha which essentially
regulates health and safety in the
workplace has put out an emergency
authorization saying if you have that
many employees or more you've got to
either require them to get vaccinated or
require them to wear masks and test for
covid at least once a week shannon
breams the fox news chief legal
correspondent and the host of fox news
at night so the other mandate dealing
with health care workers has to do with
those who would work in a facility that
receives medicare or medicaid funding
and those can be privately run or
publicly run if any of that money flows
to those facilities the people who work
there employees volunteers contractors
at any of those facilities
this promulgation or this regulation
that was promulgated would say they've
got to be vaccinated and so that's
pretty much everybody uh every at least
decent-sized healthcare facility takes
those now uh who brought the challenges
to both
well you had a number i mean with the
osha challenge in the very beginning uh
it came from companies and businesses i
mean immediately filed in every one of
the lower circuits that are the feeder
courts into the supreme court so you've
got all kinds of different agencies
states that have gotten involved um all
kinds of plaintiffs are involved there
uh the case is titled the national
federation of independent business uh
versus the department of labor so
they're kind of the spearheading group
that's gotten this case all the way to
the supreme court in the other case you
have states that are essentially
the ones who brought the case involving
the healthcare workers these states many
of them do run state-run hospital
entities or healthcare facilities so
they're suing as states saying you can't
tell us we can't have federal money
unless we do this vaccine mandate for
all those workers or employees or
contractors at these facilities so so
far the lower courts have been
more or less against the mandates right
i don't think they're completely winless
the buying administration
yeah i mean it's definitely been a mix
what happened with the osha mandate if
you remember that immediately the first
uh circuit court to hear it was the
fifth circuit and they actually uh ruled
to put thing on hold
well what happened was when there is
multi-jurisdiction legislation like this
and there was a case on this filed in
every single one of the lower circuits
there's a lottery so that all of the uh
the litigation can be put together in
one place that lottery then was assigned
to a different circuit court the sixth
circuit which actually said no we're not
going to be ban the osha uh mandate for
now so you've got to split in the
circuits but it's a technical
distinction right now because
technically the 6th circuit is
overseeing everything so essentially
it's enough that there were enough
justices who said we got to get involved
yeah so what's the method here by which
the court took this up it's an emergency
case sort of acceptance situation right
will it be a
sped up timeline for a decision as well
i think so i think we can expect that
we've seen a couple of these they're
very unusual for the court to do this
where you know it normally takes months
or even years for these case to get to
the court cases to get to the court but
in this um situation in this scenario
it's been a matter of weeks so it is
super expedited the court decided listen
these are urgent case questions that got
to be answered right now there are
people who are having decide to decide
um and employers decide do we spend the
money to go ahead and implement uh these
mandates uh employees deciding do i go
ahead and take the vaccine or do i risk
my job so
the court has definitely sped this up at
rocket speed for the way that they
normally operate so they'll hear the
cases uh today on friday both of these
cases um and we could have a decision
within days
correct me if i'm wrong is
this isn't the end of it right the court
is basically deciding whether to let the
mandates be enforced while these
challenges play out so they aren't
decisions on the mandates themselves or
do they end up doing that down the road
or have i misread this
no you're exactly right and that's a
distinction that's good for people to
understand that yes this is strictly
about whether or not these ma
vaccine mandates can be stayed for now
while they plan on the merits but what
you know most people think is like
listen if the supreme court goes through
this whole process and um strikes down
either of these um
regulations or these mandates
you have to wonder how open they're
going to be to upholding them that they
show back up here in a year because
really if they go through the lower
courts and come back it would probably
take several months to a year or more to
get them back so a lot of people think
all right listen if the buy
administration loses these mandates at
the federal level they may say
okay especially if it looks like we're
through the worst of omicron within the
next couple of weeks if they get a loss
on either of these from the supreme
court they may say
we're not going to relitigate it because
once it gets back to the court we're
likely to get the same decision or if
they lose on either of these they may
say we're going to keep fighting we
think it's important this thing is not
over every time we thought it's over
there's another wave so we're going to
stick with it are there specific
precedents the court can look to or is
this just another case about
presidential versus congressional versus
the state's authority to get things done
yeah i do think it's going to be more
wonky i think it's going to be looking
at agency law whether these agencies
osha and hhs whether those federal
agencies that are part of the executive
branch
whether they have the power to do what
they've done in these situations
obviously the plaintiffs argue it's an
overreach these were emergency
authorizations that didn't go through
the normal vetting process which there
is a formula for doing these emergency
regulations but they're going to argue
that it's just a broad overreach to tell
every employer in the country
essentially over 100 employees that you
have to do with the federal government
just months ago admitted it could not do
i mean osha does have this emergency
authority it has something to uh the
term grave danger is used they're
allowed to step in and and uh
and put these regulations in place if
there's great danger one part of the
problem is that there's that's not
defined really by anybody
um so there were mixed results
uh in court in the 70s and 80s when they
were you know looking at things like
benzene and pesticides and asbestos and
they mostly
lost in courts then
yeah and so what the language says
you know if osha is going to do this
emergency um regulation it's an
emergency temporary standard is what
it's called um they have to show that
employees are exposed to grave danger
from exposure to substances or agents
determined to be toxic or physically
harmful or from new hazards and that the
emergency standard is quote necessary to
protect employees from such danger so
obviously they're what they're arguing
is the toxic substance would be having
people in the workplace who weren't
vaccinated who could possibly um be
carrying the virus uh and in fact other
people
you know you're gonna hear the argument
now we all know vaccinated people and
boosted people who have and are
spreading um you know chronovirus the
cdc the fda the nih like everybody
admits that's actually what's happening
now so
i think that's going to that's going to
be a tough part of the argument for the
government here if their argument is we
want to keep unvaccinated people out of
the workplace because they're the ones
who would spread it when now all of
those agencies uh and the buy
administration admit that vaccinated
people are getting and spreading it i
think it it makes the argument for the
government a little tougher yeah it's
funny the timing of things and how the
science of things change like the fact
that now we know that vaccinated people
even if they're not getting is sick in
general and if they're not as infectious
there are lots and lots and lots of
breakthrough cases so you're right if we
didn't know that that things might be
different
yeah i mean we've certainly progressed a
long ways these two uh regulations from
osha and from hhs that are going to be
argued at the supreme court today came
out in november and as with everything
with this virus we learn something new
every day every week we have new data we
have new numbers and the situation has
changed significantly since november
when it seemed like for most people the
vaccines were holding um boosters were
rolling out people felt pretty good now
whether it's just omicron that has been
able to escape the vaccines and has been
much tougher for people it's created a
different situation where again you know
the admission is that vaccinated people
are getting and spreading it so
when these mandates came out that wasn't
something that we knew and now that's a
different uh ball field for the supreme
court to be playing on when they just uh
have to
now
rubber meets the road on whether these
mandates are going to be able to stand
now people in favor of these mandates or
at least
argue that they're okay to point to well
if you want to go to college you've got
to get vaccinated if you want to be in
the military you could get vaccinated i
mean the supreme court has said
also that the the college mandates are
fine and they've said that maine and new
york in this case can have their own
vaccine requirements for health care
workers
um
i guess i mentioned this before is this
something where they say look public
health decisions
aren't made by
a presidential administration
i think that the court i think it does
make a difference that we're talking
about federal regulations that the court
is dealing with because
i think there's an argument for a lot of
folks that that these health decisions
are left to localities and states and
when the federal government gets
involved and makes a sweeping nationwide
promulgation i think it's harder for the
federal government to defend that than
it would be say for a local or state
agency or entity where they are closer
to and have more power when it comes to
regulating public health so i think the
fact that these are federal makes them a
little bit more vulnerable to arguments
that they're inappropriate um but i you
know i also think you know you could
definitely put together five justices
who would say listen we're in a unique
time in history the federal government
is doing everything that it can and uh
in their assessment their judgment they
think this will lessen cases and
severity of illness and death and um you
know they've got a right to do it so
we'll see i mean i i think that it's
gonna be a close call
and the hope that you alluded to is that
all of this could be moot um if if it
drags out and drags out and drags out it
might not be as relevant to public
health if covert is less of a problem i
guess it though could set uh precedent
for future decisions
uh you know the next time something like
this happens if it happens
yeah and i think we all have to
you know assume that it will at some
point hopefully not in our lifetimes i
think we all think one is enough for us
for this generation but um but we have
to be realistic and the court is always
thinking
multi-chess steps ahead of where the
game is right now because they know
whatever they write whatever they decide
will be dependent on for
decades for centuries potentially i mean
you set a precedent and it's extremely
important so i think they're not just
looking at the immediate situation that
we're in they are most certainly
thinking about how whatever they decide
affects jurisprudence as the highest
court in the land for generations to
come so
well some of us may be a little myopic
based on whatever our personal
experience is with the mandates or with
the virus or with our families or with
our jobs they're definitely going to be
thinking multiple steps ahead uh as they
decide what they do in this case in
these two cases uh knowing that it will
impact things uh for the history of our
country
uh when do you expect that we'll hear
whether these band-aids could be
enforced for now
it's tough to figure that out we know
that they did because these expedited
cases are so rare they did the texas
abortion case they heard that and within
a couple of weeks we had a decision um
that was something they did expedited
late last year so i would imagine
knowing everything that's at stake and
the deadlines that are coming i would
say within a couple weeks is reasonable
okay
uh
okay i'll take it better than i've got
uh shannon bream anchor fox news at
night uh midnight's eastern nine
uh in the west
weeknights on fox news channel also
she's a fox news chief legal
correspondent relevant to our discussion
today and uh she got a podcast to live
in the brain my favorite podcast title
of the entire family of podcasts we have
here
shannon thanks for coming on the rundown
thank you chris
[Music]
this is janis dean with your fox news
commentary coming up
omicron is spreading like wildfire and
there's a lot of confusion about the
current isolation and travel guidelines
depending on where you are but there is
some hopeful news thursday the who
announced the number of weekly worldwide
covet deaths dropped still the case
numbers are climbing up 71 percent
globally chief medical adviser to the
biden administration dr anthony fauci at
wednesday's white house coven 19
briefing emphasized without a doubt
unequivocally we are dealing with a
highly highly transmissible variant that
spreads rapidly the data are
overwhelming in that regard during
previous waves the spikes usually
translated to a higher death toll about
two weeks later but the symptoms with
omicron are typically much milder at
least for the vaccinated domestically
the effort to strengthen kids immunity
is ramping up as omicron fuels countless
school closures across the country white
house coronavirus response coordinator
jeffrey zeitz acknowledged concerns by
saying
parents want schools open and experts
are clear that in-person learning is
best for kids physical and mental health
and for their education and the
president couldn't be clearer
schools in this country should remain
open children ages 12 to 15 can get
their booster as can kids as young as 5
years old with immune deficiencies so
what does that mean for schools and can
they get back on track in the near
future i think that there's been the
ability to have a safe return to schools
even in the pre-vaccine era because we
know that schools are not major centers
of transmission at least not the
educational component of schools
extracurricular activities are a little
bit different that's dr amish adulja
infectious disease specialist at john
hopkins university and we've got best
practices to keep kids in school to keep
in-person learning going
and these types of practices were
derived in an era when the pandemic was
raging
outside the school doors but the schools
are relatively safe and i think
it really is something that has to be
prioritized and it becomes even easier
when you have teachers vaccinated staff
vaccinated children vaccinated and high
risk individuals able to be boosted it
really it should not be the default
anymore to have schools going to virtual
it really has to be seen as a failure
when that occurs and it has to be
avoided at all costs and schools should
be the very very last thing to close and
the very very first thing to open
and i do think we are seeing a lot of
schools close just as they opened up
after the new year and the holiday break
for kids across the country what do you
say to parents who are simply too afraid
to send their kids back to class right
now
children generally tend to be spared
from the severe consequences of disease
and the best way to protect your child
from any chance of infection is to get
them vaccinated then we know that
children in the united states are one of
the lowest vaccinated groups a parent
should also ask that their schools have
their teachers be required to be
vaccinated i think as a condition of
employment that also makes schools safe
but
you have to
keep also in mind that schools have been
through this
and have survived with minimal
disruption when they actually put in
place the best practices to keep covet
19 from interrupting school and i think
that that's what people should be
reassured about there is a method to do
this that's been shown to be safe and we
know that keeping children outside of
school actually damages them and you
have to think not just about the coveted
related well-being of a child but the
overall well-being of a child and
in-person schooling is something that
adds to the overall well-being of
children and i think parents with the
exception of some who may have high-risk
children that are immunocompromised who
had a transplant that's a little bit
different but for most the vast majority
of children without any medical problems
i think school is one of the safest
places they can be
yeah and we've seen just the devastating
mental toll that this has taken on
really the this generation of kids in
school who've missed out on some of
those formative years of learning and
social activity and throughout the
pandemic we have seen that
the cases among children have been much
lower as you alluded to but with this
new variant omicron
is it affecting kids any differently
omicron is going to basically infect
everyone and it has an easier time
infecting people who are not fully
vaccinated and hospitalized in people
who are not fully vaccinated
and as i said earlier children tend to
have the lowest vaccination rates in
this country of any age group so omicron
is going to infect them as cases go up
children are going to get infected
especially as children because they're
spared from severe consequence of
disease are back to a lot of their
activities with sports and
extracurricular activities but there's
no evidence that this is more severe in
children than any other variant may have
been
we are seeing some hospitalizations
increase but that's to be expected as
cases increase
a proportion of them are going to result
in hospitalization primarily in those
children with underlying conditions but
we're also seeing
hospitals being really aggressive at
testing everybody that's admitted to
make sure that they capture all the
covet 19 cases so there are some
hospitals reporting that children are
testing positive incidentally when they
come in for other reasons but but in
general i think it still remains true
that children are spared severe
consequences of disease yes there are
children that get severe illness they
tend to be those that have some risk
factor for disease and in the vaccine
makes this a lot
a lot easier to navigate for parents
and each variant we've seen a triggering
of different symptoms so what are the
main symptoms that we're seeing for
omicron right now
omicron seems to be more
mild in the sense that it's causing a
lot more upper respiratory symptoms
rather than lower respiratory symptoms
so more of the congestion scratchy sore
throats
those types of cold symptoms that that
we are all so used to having and less of
the
loss of taste and smell which had really
been very specific for covet 19. so it
does have a little bit of a different
spectrum but they all the variants and
all the other respiratory viruses sort
of overlap so it's really impossible to
tell them apart
and as we're seeing this variant really
rage across the country in the world
right now there's
some confusion so i'd love to get your
perspective on that with the cdc
revising the isolation time for infected
people from ten to five days and of
course
now people don't need to test out they
can just opt out of staying home if
they're symptoms free after um again
five days so with all of that being said
and there is confusion how do you see
these advised guidelines what's your
stance on that
it's always been the case that the
10-day isolation period was
one-size-fits-all and it really didn't
reflect
when people were contagious for the most
part and so we've been kind of clamoring
for some time to decrease the isolation
period because we know that many people
couldn't do it 10 days is very
disruptive it was discouraging people
from getting tested because they didn't
want to isolate for 10 days
and the data from case contact
investigation showed that the bulk of
transmission was occurring in the first
five or so days of
of infection so i think that the the cdc
the spirit of this guidance was really
good it was about trying to reduce the
harm the virus causes making guidance
that people would follow but it often
got muddled or at least the messaging
got muddled because it occurred at the
time when there was an omicron surge
when there was a shortage of home tests
and it got and it seemed to be driven
not by science even though i do believe
it was driven by science and then they
got criticism for not including testing
but when they did put testing in they
they kind of put it in such a muddled
wishy-washy way that it actually
discourages testing saying if you want
to test if you haven't accessed then you
have to isolate for five more days if
it's positive so it to me it's it's it's
more not a scientific issue but just
really uh bad communication that got
picked up by the press and picked up by
critics and and really made
uh
it really looks bad for the cdc and it
makes it very hard to make this
this guidance actionable but in in
general what we're trying to do is
reduce the harm the virus causes and if
you've got isolation periods that are
you know perfect by the textbook and
nobody can follow them they're not very
good and i think what we want to do is
embrace you know harm reduction types of
philosophies and if people can isolate
for five days
i think that's that's better than not
isolating at all but we have to come to
a sustainable approach to this because
even if these infections are mild if you
have to isolate for ten days that's not
mild on your life and the disruption to
your life but i think what it should be
really gauged to do is prevent the bulk
of transmission be something that people
can actually do and not discourage
people from getting tested and not be
one size fits all
yeah and we had you on the run down at
the end of november when the variant was
first discovered and you said at the
time that the virus is becoming more
transmissible
but not more deadly has anything
surprised you about the spreading of
this new variant since you last joined
us
not particularly i think what we got was
more data that sort of supported the
early indications we had about its
transmissibility and its severity
i think what's interesting about it is
that it follows this kind of
two-week cycle
versus a months long cycle for other
variants
at least based on the data that we've
seen in the united kingdom in south
africa it will be really interesting to
see how well it follows that pattern in
the united states which would mean that
we might see see peaks starting in the
next couple of days
in places like new york city that were
hit hard first
looking ahead at the next inevitable
variant do you think that that one will
also be more transmissible but less
severe
there's always going to be lots of
variants generated some of them are not
going to take off or go anywhere so you
won't even hear about them but i think
the next dominant variant is likely to
be in the pattern of omicron because
what we're seeing is the virus kind of
moving towards
the way other family members other
coronavirus family members behave where
they reinfect basically at will after a
period of time and usually cause mild
illness because that's advantageous for
transmission if people are out about
doing things with mild illness they can
infect other people so i think that
omicron might be the first step down
that path to
coven 19 being like the fifth seasonal
coronavirus that we deal with we'll have
to see but i mean it certainly looks
like that and i don't think that you're
going to see the the virus a variant
become dominant that is more deadly um i
think that's something that doesn't make
sense for it from an evolutionary
perspective i mean it would be an
unlikely possibility i think what we see
is more transmissibility more immune
evasion that's what evolution would
favor
if future variants continue to weaken
are we likely to need more boosters in
the future or could a
vaccine once a year really be enough to
protect herself
it's unclear how that that's all going
to play out because it comes back to
what the goals may be
with covet 19 control are we trying to
prevent serious illness hospitalization
and death or are we trying to block all
infections because if we're trying to
prevent serious disease hospitalization
and death and i think that's the right
goal
our current vaccines are holding up
really really well
at that even without a booster in most
people uh that they're spared from
severe consequences and i think but i
think if we're going to be trying to
block all infections i think an update
of the vaccine probably makes the most
sense
because we're still targeting the wuhan
strain of the virus and where several
variants down the line whether or not
that has to be annual or what frequency
i think that's too early it's too early
to say that we don't have enough data to
be able to say that for sure and also
there is the prospect of universal
coronavirus vaccines that have made it
through phase one clinical trials and
are
are moving along sort of outside of the
headlines but they're there and that
might be what we eventually see as a
more universal type corona virus vaccine
that covers you know all variants as
well as maybe even picks up some of the
other coronaviruses that cause common
colds
dr a mishidolja thanks as always for
your time
thanks
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
for the last 224 years a man has been
the commanding officer for the oldest
commissioned warship in the world that's
still afloat as of january 21st that
streak will be broken the navy says that
commander billy j farrell will take over
that day becoming the first female
commanding officer of the uss
constitution the constitution was
nicknamed old ironsides for its
reputation of cannonballs bouncing off
its wooden hull during the war of 1812.
it also defended parts of the ocean
around the u.s from 1797 to 1855 and
destroyed or captured at least 33 enemy
ships it's currently stationed in
boston's charlestown navy yard and women
now make up more than a third of the
80-person crew cbs boston reports that
the current commanding officer of the
constitution john benda said in a
statement that the historic barrier is
quote long overdue to be broken and that
he couldn't think of a better candidate
for the job commander farrell is not the
only woman making military history this
week the uss abraham lincoln became the
first ever aircraft carrier to be
skippered by a woman when it departed
san diego for its scheduled deployment
stars and stripes reports that captain
amy bauernschmidt assumed command of the
vessel in august she graduated from the
naval academy in 1994 the first
graduating class in which women were
allowed to serve aboard combatant ships
and aircraft
captain bauernschmidt also earned a
masters at the naval war college was
designated a naval aviator in 1996 and
has 3 thousand flight hours and numerous
commendations tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
janice dean
what's on your mind it's been almost two
years since the deaths of my in-laws
mickey and dee newman who contracted
covet 19 in their separate elder care
facilities in new york city our families
were never notified of governor andrew
cuomo's mandate to send over 9 000
coveted positive patients into new york
nursing homes and we still don't know
why he decided to do it there were other
facilities provided by the federal
government he could have used like the
uss comfort ship and the javits center
that went virtually empty without any
coped patients instead the governor's
health department decided to put the
sickest people into the places where our
most vulnerable resided
since may of 2020 myself and thousands
of families have demanded answers and
accountability into why those deadly
decisions were made but instead of
addressing why this tragedy happened on
his watch cuomo did everything he could
to cover it up and despite the disgraced
governor's resignation in august
it appears that little by little those
in power are helping him get away with
his corruptive criminal behavior
on monday cuomo's team announced that
the manhattan district attorney's office
were dropping their nursing home probe
according to the new york post the
investigation under xda cyrus vance jr
was quashed last thursday right before
the new d.a alvin bragg was sworn in
how convenient and how telling
many of us are disturbed and angered by
this news especially since this now
seems like a deal was made before vance
left office and hours before the new d.a
moved in peter arbini a fierce advocate
whose father contracted kovit in a
brooklyn nursing home and died in the
spring of last year says that data
manipulation false public doh reports
the false reporting of the death toll
and the false testimony given to the
senate and the assembly are a violation
of law and public trust because they
were driven by personal profit and gain
this cannot be overlooked
the nursing home tragedy is not the only
thing that cuomo and his team are trying
to get away with
several of the charges of abusive
behavior towards women in his office are
also quietly going away the albany
westchester and nassau county da's
dropped their charges into cuomo's
despicable behavior despite quote
credible and deeply troubling
allegations
lindsey boylan a former aide to cuomo
and the first woman to bravely speak out
about his sexual harassment towards her
says that all these various drop charges
are about fear
fear of a man with money and without
scruples and fear tainting by continued
focus on abuse of power
my friend and fellow advocate new york
state assemblyman ron kim chairman of
the assembly aging committee is still
optimistic that the other ongoing probes
by the fbi the doj and the ag are more
serious and that justice will eventually
prevail
according to the new york post the fed's
probe is still examining the cuomo
administration's actions relating to the
nursing home deaths and the fbi is still
looking into cuomo's 5.1 advance for his
book american crisis leadership lessons
from the covet 19 pandemic which was
negotiated and published while he was
being accused of covering up the total
nursing home death toll
and just because cuomo is no longer in
power doesn't mean the rest of us are
done with trying to hold him accountable
or call out his continued corruption
because although our loved ones can
never defend themselves it's up to us to
keep using our voices for justice on
their behalf
janice dean
fox news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
jason in the house the jason chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as i take on american
life politics and entertainment
subscribe now on foxnewspodcast.com
or wherever you download podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes